Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Ninus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, was war eigentlich dein erfolgreichster Misserfolg?
Mein bester Fail war, als ich mit meinen neuen Inlineskates als erste Amtshandlung über,
zwei Paletten gesprungen bin und mir bei der Landung den äh linken Arm
vollständig gebrochen habe und dann erstmal längere Zeit nicht mehr in Skates fahren konnte.
Super.
Ja, nicht alles, was man sich vornimmt, äh klappt und äh läuft so, wie man sich das,
und den die Niederlage zu akzeptieren gehört mittlerweile eigentlich auch schon zum guten Ton, nicht wahr?
Ja, natürlich, also so, ich meine, Fail Collections auf YouTube so, das ist irgendwie das.
Richtig große Erfolge.
Große Erfolge, die Menschen da irgendwie.
Generiert auch Klickzahlen, schick Zahlen generieren auch entsprechende Werbeeinnahmen. Ja, da kann man dann in äh
zusammenarbeiten mit Google äh richtig Geld scheffelt, wie ja verschiedene äh Schminktipps und andere populäre Angebote im Internet äh
Ein das andere beweisen. Da könnte sich ja dann unter Umständen,
kriegen sie vielleicht ein bisschen was von der Kohle wieder rein, die irgendwie gerade so ein bisschen äh durch die Hände äh rinnt.
Videos ist auf jeden Fall sind das geil.
Vielleicht könnte man auch einfach die Bild-Zeitung mal umbenennen in Fail. Ja, da hätte das ja auch eine gewisse Attraktivität so auf die neue Generation, ne. Sowas würde ich mir wünschen zum Kongress.
So eine Bild-Zeitung, wo nicht Bild steht, sondern,
Fail und dann halt auch wirklich so die besten Fails.
Off.
Ne, die halt entsprechend, ne, mit Seite drei und das volle Programm, äh.
Ja, aber dann halt mal andersrum halt so.
Also hast du mitbekommen, die haben jetzt hier zum neunten November wieder ihr Ding da verteilt, ne, um Leuten wieder den Briefkasten vollgestopft damit,
äh mit der Bild-Zeitung, ne? Mhm.
Ach, Rene. Nee, habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Zum neunten November. Gestern.
Gestern, glaube ich. Oder vielleicht haben wir auch einen Tag davor.
Sonntags, ja.
Kasten gesteckt. Ähm wahrscheinlich einen Tag vorher im Briefkasten gespielt. Bei mir nicht. Das wissen sie inzwischen. Ist das bei mir nicht machen sollen?
Aha, dann sitzt was oder wie? Vielleicht haben sie Friedrichshain einfach komplett rausgelassen.
Habe ich das, habe ich das eigentlich immer erzählt, dass sie mich angezeigt haben?
Die Bild-Zeitung.
Verlag heute gegen mich vorgehen, wegen äh Computersabotage.
Ja, war das nicht mit Netzpolitik? Ja ja.
Genau, ja, ja, genau. Weil ich da erklärt hatte, wie man die erfolgreich daran hindern kann,
so 'ne Bild Zeitung da reinzuschicken und den außerdem noch ein bisschen Arbeit machen kann,
Ja, da wollten sie mich äh nichts draus geworden, da stattdessen haben die ja dann eine ein,
Prüfverfahren vom vom Datenschutz Berliner Datenschutz bekommen. Naja, ähm.
Kratze doch gar nicht irgendwie äh weißt du? Achselspringer geht, das ist ein großer Traditionsverlag. Wir haben einfach die haben einfach alle Karten in der Hand und denen kann keiner was.
Na ja äh vielleicht um noch kurz diese Geschichte zu Ende zu bringen, weil ich würde das gerne noch kurz äh sicherstellen äh klarstellen. Ähm,
Weil wenn man schon irgendwie gegen mich versucht vorzugehen
dann äh sollte man sich natürlich besser überlegen. Das Problem war, dass denen die äh dass die tatsächlich unter diesen Anfragen dann ähm,
kleine äh kleinere Schluckäufe auf dem ähm,
hatten.
Ja, aber sie mussten dann jeder einzelne, jedes einzelne Datenschutz ersuchen, äh beantworten.
Ja, ist halt so. Ähm.
So ist es. Man muss sich auch um die Details kümmern. Da dir auch ganz.
Ne, ist halt gesetzt, ne. Ist ganz, ist ganz günstig. Ich habe das mal irgendwann für Netzpolitik org aufgeschrieben und auch in der Wikipedia bin ich da verewigt als.
Ist der Typ, der das.
Die letzte Mähbombe in Deutschland, die hier angezeigt wurde. Äh oder.
So, das ist also schon relevant.
Nee, nee, ist nur im Wikipedia Artikel Mailbombe. Da habe ich halt sehr dafür gekämpft, dass da auch drinsteht, dass es keine war. Oder ich zumindest nicht kriminell. Na ja,
Äh Springer hat einen hat einen wunderschönen äh Tweet und eine wunderschöne,
Konferenz veröffentlicht, nachdem sie ja jetzt mit ihren Angeboten,
Was war das denn? Computerbild, Autobild und was haben sie noch? Äh,
wofür haben sie noch Leistungsschutzgeld in Anspruch nehmen wollen gegenüber,
Die Welt.
Computerbild, Bild und Sportbild, glaube ich. Das waren die vier.
Genau,
So und das war jetzt, also wir erinnern uns, die Geschichte war Leistungsschutzrecht haben sie bekommen. Ähm VG Media hat angefangen, das zu er äh verlangen
zum Einsatz gebracht,
Google hat aber dann gesagt, ja, nee, finden wir eigentlich nicht. Wollen wir nicht?
Und hat sich dann eben darauf reduziert, die Inhalte auf ihre, in ihre Listings zu nehmen, die sie nehmen durften, nämlich den Titel
Punkt. Keine Anreißertexte, keine Bilder. Ähm irgendwann hat dann die VG Media ähm kalte Füße bekommen. Ähm das war also die,
rechte Verwertungsorganisation, in der die Leistungsschutzrecht
Anspruch nehmenden Verlage, sich dann äh organisiert haben,
Und ähm es blieb nur der Springer Verlag zurück mit,
mit diesen mit einer Hand voll entscheidender äh,
Publikation und sagte, mit denen machen wir es nicht. Ähm,
Also mit denen bestehen wir weiterhin auf das Leistungsschutzrecht und geben keine äh widerrufliche Gratis-Einwilligung,
und jetzt äh stellten sie also öffentlichkeitswirksam fest,
Ähm brach ihr Such-Traffic, um fast vierzig Prozent ein,
Ihr Google News Traffic umfasst achtzig Prozent.
Und ähm.
Also die, die Antwort war natürlich ein herzliches nein! Doch! Oh! Aus der äh! Twitter-Rosphäre,
Ähm das war also wirklich ähm das, ich meine, da konnte ja jetzt niemand mit rechnen, ne. Also wer hätte damit rechnen können, dass wenn die,
äh auf einer Suchmaschine weniger attraktiv dargestellt werden.
Sie dann äh Traffic verlieren. Ähm.
Ja, also es ist, es ist sehr ähm sehr amüsant, dass sie es da auf die harte Tour lernen.
Aber man.
Aber man die die Tweets dazu kann man sich echt mal äh.
Die Antworten sind wirklich sehr lustig.
Ähm aber,
ähm der wichtige Hinweis hier natürlich ist, das ist natürlich jetzt deren Strategie. Ja, also ihre Lesart ist natürlich, dass sie sagen,
Damit haben wir gezeigt, dass Google uns,
wirtschaftlich dafür bestraft,
wenn wir ein Recht in Anspruch nehmen,
Das ist der Deutsche Bundestag zu billig. Das ist also ihre Lesart, die sie jetzt da auch propagieren, ne, mit mit den ähm Wortmeldungen von Matthias Döffner und Christoph Käse.
Das Interessante ist doch, dass sozusagen Google ihn eigentlich vorher, indem sie das Snippet genommen haben, also im Sinne von mehr als der Titel plus B plus äh sofern vorhandene Bild Plus eben Textausschnitt, quasi,
Eine bessere Dienstleistung erbringt, ihnen Kunden zuzuführen,
genau für das bessere Dienstleistung erbringen ohne es überhaupt jemals danach gefragt haben im Übrigen,
Dafür möchte dann Springer sozusagen Geld haben. Also es ist einfach so was von,
Durcheinander an der Stelle argumentativ, das tut wirklich schon ein bisschen weh.
Ja, äh das ist in der Tat ähm eine eine Argumentation, der es äh äh schwer fällt, zu folgen,
Aber äh das betrifft dieses gesamte Leistungsschutzrecht,
und auch das haben sie erfolgreich hinbekommen. Also ich bin mal gespannt
ähm ob sie damit nicht tatsächlich durchkommen. Deswegen sagt Herr Döpfner, das war vielleicht der erfolgreichste Misserfolg, den wir je hatten. So traurig ist,
aber jetzt wissen wir sehr präzise wie massiv die Folgen der Diskriminierung sind, wie sich die Marktmacht von Google tatsächlich auswirkt und wie Google jeden bestraft
der ein Recht wahrnimmt, dass der Deutsche Bundestag ihm eingeräumt hat. Ja. Und das ist jetzt deren ähm,
Ja, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, Argumentationslinie, ne, aber das ist halt.
Ja, aber was erwarten sie denn? Was erwarten sie denn? Also, also ob, als ob der Axel-Springer-Verlag in einer entsprechenden Situation auch automatisch irgendwie äh auf einmal anfangen würde, Geld zu bezahlen. Sie würden's genauso sein lassen.
Nee, natürlich. Ähm aber der die Gefahr ist,
Also dass dass diese Logik von vorne bis hinten absolut verquer und bescheuert ist, äh wissen glaube ich inzwischen
alle äh Hörerinnen dieser Sendung und auch alle weiteren Menschen da draußen, die sich ein paar Minuten damit auseinandergesetzt haben. Aber äh es gibt immer noch einen großen Teil der Menschen da draußen, die sich nicht ein paar Minuten damit auseinandergesetzt haben und denen kannst du relativ einfach sagen
Pass mal auf, äh, Demokratie hier, ne? Wichtig, kennst du ja. Ähm,
Medien, freie Medien und so da drin, ne? Sie wissen, wie schlecht es den Verlagen geht und so, das ist aber sehr wichtige Stütze unserer,
wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir nicht so ein Zeitungssterben bekommen, wie in den USA, wo das am Ende nur noch so eine
eine Zeitung gibt, ne? Wichtig, müssen wir drauf achten. Und jetzt gucken wir, was was Google gerade macht. Die die machen da irgendwie vierzig bis achtzig Prozent
Trafficeinbrüche gerade, weil ihnen die Position der Verlage nicht passt, obwohl die ja durch, obwohl wir ja extra dieses Gesetz gemacht haben, das geht ja so nicht,
So und das ist halt ein schöner Elevator Pitch, den du schön durchsprechen kannst. Äh für jeden, der äh sich eben nicht mit dieser Sache mal kurz auseinandergesetzt hat oder vielleicht sogar,
ähm sage ich mal, gerade auf einer Linie ist, wie der größere Teil der Bundesregierung, dass alles, was,
Google ist, erstmal grundsätzlich gut ist.
Es ändert einfach auch nichts, nichts an der Tatsache, dass das einfach alles vollkommen vollkommener.
Ja, ist vollkommen bescheuert, aber das haben wir ja schon mehrmals hier erörtert. Äh.
Aber ich stimme dir zu, dass das so ein bisschen äh die Gefahr läuft, dass es dann vom Bundestagsabgeordneten entsprechend aufgenommen wird.
Jeder, jeder, der irgendwie halbwegs nachdenkt, das kann er nur drüber lachen. Äh Christoph Käse sagt dann auch nochmal, also das ist ja der der geistige Vater des Urheberrechtes, ähm schrieb dann,
Die Gratis-Lizenz an Google wurde jedoch gegen der Will, gegen den Willen der VG Media und der Verlage erteilt, wegen des Mis,
Drucks des Marktbeherrschers. Sie ist das Ergebnis einer Nötigung.
Nötigung. Ja. Ist das echt so super.
Ja, aber so ist es nun mal, ne? Und das, das Problem ist, also ich bin da ähm tatsächlich ein bisschen nach wie vor voller Sorge.
Dass sie, dass sie da jetzt noch irgendwie durchkommen. Die einzig sinnvolle,
ich jetzt ganz ehrlich sagen, die einzig wirklich saubere Argumentation dagegen, also dieses äh ähm,
erwartet ihr denn und so? Das ist und Häme und Lachen. Das halte ich für nur so mittelhilfreich. Ähm,
Denn das haben wir ja schon vorher äh versucht zu erklären, diese Zusammenhänge. Sinnvoll finde ich, was Stefan Nickelmeier jetzt schreibt und sagt, ähm
Google bekommt eine Vorzugsbehandlung von Axel Springer. Der Axel-Springer-Konzern diskriminiert,
Suchmaschinen und Aggregatoren. Denn von denen nimmt er ja Leistungsschutzgeld.
Und nur Google äh gibt er eine ähm eine Erlaubnis äh zur Gratis-Lizenz.
Ich meine, es gibt doch nicht wirklich auch nur einen einzigen Anbieter von irgendwelchen vergleichbaren,
News-Indizes, die tatsächlich Geld an Springer zahlen oder an die in irgendein Mitglied der VW Media.
Das weiß ich nicht, das weiß ich nicht. Also da äh.
Kenne bisher zumindest nur Berichte von äh Unternehmen, die sich zurückgezogen haben.
Ähm.
Da bin ich mir, also ich äh glaube,
dass es da wahrscheinlich eine kleine Koalition von deutschen Unternehmen gibt, die sich da einfach nicht zu äußern, um den Anschein aufrechtzuerhalten. Dass sie sich diesem Gesetz äh.
Nicht beugen, als dann aber trotzdem tun.
Doch, dass sie sich diesen, dass sie sich diesem Gesetz gebeugt hätten,
Also sagen wir mal, du bist jetzt ähm,
Die Deutsche Telekom mit ihrer T-Online Startseite da. Dann hast du ja auch.
Dann kämpfst du ja eigentlich an in dieser Stelle mit dem Springer Verlag seit ein Seitwald deines Feindes Feinde ja deine Freunde sind. So, das heißt die Deutsche Telekom äh,
ist natürlich nicht schlecht beraten. Äh,
Wenn sie nicht tatsächlich einen Springer zahlt, das trotzdem nicht öffentlich zu machen und so zu tun,
äh würden sie da jetzt grade äh belastet? Weil der böse Google ähm,
ungerecht belastet, weil der böse Google gerade die Zeitungsverlage erpresst. Weißt du?
Ja, na ja, ist ja eigentlich auch nicht, also auch dem kann ich nicht so ganz folgen. Also, ich meine, wir wissen nicht, ob da irgendwelche ähm Verträge geschlossen sind, ob da irgendwelche Lizenzen
gezahlt werden, wir wissen es nicht, zumindest haben wir vorhin noch nichts gehört, aber,
haben wir auf jeden Fall von der ganzen Menge Ablehnung und Auslistung.
Auch von diesen Portalen.
Ja, ja, äh.
Von daher passt das für meinen Geschmack alles nicht so richtig zusammen. Warum sollten die auch für so etwas Geld bezahlen wollen? Also es ist einfach absurd.
Ja, das äh aber das bringt also der Punkt ist Tim, das ist absurd, aber das haben wir jetzt hier wirklich seit Jahren äh immer wieder betont und das sollte auch allen klar sein. Meine Sorge ist, dass sie es trotzdem weitertreiben. Und sie haben jetzt.
Gut, aber in welche Richtung.
Die Richtung ist ja vorgegeben, die wollen Geld haben. So und sie werden mit dieser äh,
dieses Narrativ, was sie dieser Sache jetzt geben, wird bei einer bestimmten Klientel ziemlich gut verfangen.
Ja, aber was ist denn sozusagen was für was erwartest du für einen konkreten Vorstoß? Weil ich meine, jetzt haben sie ja irgendwie.
Bin nach wie vor, ich bin nach wie vor davon äh überzeugt, dass sie ähm,
das ihre Argumentationslinie sein wird, Google,
hält sich nicht ans Gesetz und nutzt dazu eine Markt beherrschende Stellung aus und deswegen geht halt nicht.
Aber sie halten sich ja ans Gesetz.
Ja, da Tim.
Entschuldigung.
Ist es einfach nur die Railing. Wenn du da jetzt nämlich mit mit sinnvollen Argumenten dich der Sache näherst.
Entschuldigung, ich werde sofort auf nicht mehr ganz so sinnvolle Argumente umschalten.
Das jetzt hier gerade mal zu.
Nein, was ich versuche nachzuvollziehen ist,
Wenn sie jetzt weitere Schritte unternehmen wollen, würden, was sie vielleicht wollen und über das sie bestimmt irgendwie nachdenken, was könnten diese Schritte sein, also auf worauf wollen sie ein äh Einfluss nehmen,
man könnte natürlich jetzt das Leistungsschutzrecht als solches noch einmal überarbeit,
und nochmal in irgendeiner Form verschärfen, aber ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, in welche Richtung sie das verschärfen wollen, weil es letzten Endes zu den selben Effekten führen würde
Ähm das andere, was bisher in der Diskussion aufkam, war das Kartellgesetz zu ändern. Ja. Ja. Äh in welcher Hinsicht,
zu ändern,
Das ist sozusagen meine Frage. Also wenn du sagst, irgendwas droht, dann frage ich, ja was droht denn? Also was denkst du, was droht? Nicht, dass ich denke,
Da droht nichts, ich sehe das durchaus äh ähnlich zu dir, dass,
dass sie jetzt nicht so ohne weitere Sicht da geschlagen geben wollen, geschweige denn ähm vor allem,
der Eindruck, dass sie irgendwie geschlagen worden sind, wird sie wahrscheinlich schon mal sehr stören. Das ist irgendwie überhaupt nicht ihre Linie.
Nee, das ist doch aber.
Deswegen frage ich mich, was soll man jetzt erahnen? Also was, was, was, was, was, was meinst du, was ein äh Feld sein kann, in dem der nächste Vorschuss stattfindet?
Weil das jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so unsere Aufgabe ist, jetzt irgendwie für Axel Springer darüber nachzudenken,
wo sie jetzt politisch als nächstes vorgehen können.
Das tun sie doch jetzt gerade. Das ist doch genau das, wovon hier die ganze Zeit die Rede ist. Ihre Argumentation für die für die Zukunft dieser Angelegenheit ist, dass sie sagen, hier wir haben einen konkreten, wirtschaftlichen Schaden,
dadurch, dass wir auf unser Recht pochen. Es ist eine es ist eine unsinnige Logik, denn in Wirklichkeit ähm ist ist das das, was gesetzlich richtig ist,
Ja, das ist das, was da steht. Google darf es nicht tun,
wenn sie keine Lizenz bekommen. Google äh und Springer haben sich nicht auf eine äh Lizenzbedingung auf Lizenzbedingungen einigen können. Entsprechend äh fährt Google auf das Minimum zurück,
Und das ist natürlich auch von diesem Gesetz absolut gedeckt. So, du kannst ja nicht kannst ja keine, keine Zwangslizenzierung machen.
Ne, das ist ja der, der logische Fehler. Aber was sie jetzt machen, ist darauf hinzuarbeiten, äh dieses Bild von der bösen Marktmacht Google, die andere erpresst ähm,
stärker zu zementieren. Und das ist genau diese diese Argumentationslinie, die sie jetzt fahren. Und ähm damit rennen sie eben an bestimmten Stellen offene Türen ein.
Und,
deswegen ja auch dieses, das war der erfolgreichste Misserfolg. Wir konnten der Welt zeigen, wie fürchterlich der Google ist,
Wie schlimm der ist, der muss ja Einhalt geboten werden.
Und damit machen sie jetzt weiter. Und gerade im Wirtschaftsministerium haben sie damit ja, du hattest das ja äh auch schon gerade kurz angesprochen. Da können sie ja sogar sagen, wir äh wir wollen das Kartellrecht ändern. Dann wird gesagt, ja, könnte man mal drüber nachdenken.
Ja, die Frage ist, in welche Richtung.
Das wissen die ja selber nicht. Die sind ja noch nicht mal in der Lage irgendwie einen Meter zu denken. Die sind ja noch nicht mal in der Lage, dass sie,
Ergebnis nicht vorhersehen konnten, was ihnen seit Jahren jeder sagt, der irgendwie eine Minute über dieses Thema nachdenkt,
Ja. Man weiß es nicht, Tim. Man weiß es nicht.
Was werden diese Laserhirne als nächstes ausgraben.
Du musst jetzt endlich aufhören. Da logisch drüber nachzudenken.
Ich habe das schon länger versucht äh.
Rauszuhalten. Das ist natürlich auch etwas schwierig, sich auf so ein Niveau runterzudenken.
Ja. Trink mal noch was.
Mehr Alkohol. Na ja, wir schreiten voran. Ja, Shopping Time.
Ja, der BND möchte shoppen gehen. BND ähm.
Mit der Mode gehen, würde ich sagen.
Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Man auch mal ein bisschen einkaufen.
Ja, also da kursiert offensichtlich kursieren Informationen äh über die,
Pläne, äh die der BND so in den nächsten Jahren hat, wofür der Geld ausgeben möchte. Ähm.
Jetzt habe ich hier dieses Pad kaputt gemacht.
Das ist irgendwie vom Spiegel aufgegriffen worden oder wo kommen diese Informationen her?
Das hat
hat äh haben mehrere News,
äh so äh gebracht. Das war irgendwie ja immer so diese ganzen,
Ähm mit dem mit einem sehr schönen Titelbild, was ich da gerade sehe, eine Anklage gegen,
meine Generation.
Ähm.
Beiseite.
Ähm,
Es geht hier, also der Spiegel hat hauptsächlich darum darüber gesprochen, dass der BND plant, viereinhalb Millionen Euro bis zweitausendzwanzig auszugeben für Zero-Day Exploits.
Für die Leute, die noch nicht äh abgespeichert haben, was das ist, das sind sozusagen bisher unver
öffentliche Schwachstellen, Sicherheitslücken in Systemen aller Art
die halt,
die einfach auf Vorrat gehalten werden, solange, bis es auch entsprechende
Käufer gibt, die bereit sind, dafür Geld auszugeben, weil natürlich so eine Sicherheitslücke einem auch einen, na ja, entweder Geldwerten oder eben auch strategischen Vorteil geben können, weil's eben die Penetration von Systemen
erlaubt, die anderen so jetzt erstmal nicht bekannt sind.
Genau und da gibt's ein ähm ganz florierenden Markt, der offensichtlich durch ähm,
einerseits Geheimdienste, andererseits ähm so die Vermutung auch durch äh Kriminelle ähm befeuert wird,
wo dann eben Angebote gemacht werden, wie zum Beispiel durch den äh durch den Anbieter wupen,
bieten dir quasi so ein Explode-Abo an,
ähm und sagen dir also okay, wir geben dir ähm,
unbekannte nichtöffentlich bekannte äh Angriffsmöglichkeiten auf äh bestimmte Software ähm die geben sogar eine Garantie dazu. Das heißt, sie haben im Zweifelsfall mehrere Zero Days, die sie danach äh Bedarf ihren Kunden geben können. Kriegst sowas wie eine sechsmonatige
ähm.
Garantie, dass sie immer in der Lage sind, irgendwas zu liefern.
Das denn? Wie das denn?
Wie ich gerade schon sagte, die äh eigentlich nur da sie ja nicht unter Kontrolle haben, welche anderen Sicherheitsforscher eventuell die Sicherheitslücke in den sechs Monaten finden und äh wie es sich gehört, reporten und.
Nehmen sie gegebenenfalls einen anderen noch kostenlos dazu.
Im Zweifelsfall einfach noch was in der Tasche oder sagen okay, wenn das passiert, dann äh,
haben wir eben da drauf gespielt und geben die anteilig die Kohle zurück oder so, ne. Also es sind ja alles nur ähm immer äh irgendwelche Produkt,
oder so, aus denen diese Informationen stammen. Fakt ist, wer äh die die Sicherheitsforschung,
in solchen Bereichen ähm lässt sich durch den Verkauf solcher äh sehr, sehr lukrativ finanzieren und es gibt kaum andere äh,
Möglichkeiten, die.
Die nur ähnlich hohe äh Erlöse erzielen, ja? Das heißt, als Sicherheitsforscher ähm,
Geld zu verdienen, ne? Und,
Die Alternative, die du jetzt vielleicht hast, ist irgendwie du könntest in so ein Prozess gehen, da kriegst du, wenn du Pech hast, gar nichts dafür, ähm wenn du Glück hast, äh wird der Hersteller dich
für deine Meldung dann nochmal sich erkennlich zeigen und dich vielleicht mit einem Beratervertrag anstellen oder sowas, ne?
Vielleicht möchtest du auch hingehen und den den Anbieter erpressen. Äh das ist natürlich äh auch noch teilweise finanziell lukrativ, aber mit dem mit einem sehr hohen äh juristischen Risiko verbunden
Das heißt, so wirklich gibt es im Moment,
sage ich mal, der finanzielle Anreiz für Sicherheitsforscher ist in diesem Zero-Day-Handel äh am stärksten,
Und das liegt eben daran, dass da äh ja Kriminelle, Akteure und Geheimdienste auf diesem Markt unterwegs sind, die da die Preise auch in entsprechend in die Höhe treiben.
Sagt er, das BSI, Sie haben bis zwanzig bis September zwanzig vierzehn, also bis vor Kurzem einen Vertrag mit Wuten unterhalten und das Ziel dieses Vertrages selber gewesen, äh die Netze, die Regierungsnetze zu schützen,
Freue ich mich natürlich, wenn Wuppen ein eine, eine, eine.
Garantie raus gibt. Funktioniert sechs Monate.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ich glaube, das war Gamma, die das getan haben. Ich bin mir nicht ganz äh wir hatten darüber gesprochen, da müssen wir nochmal ein Lokbuchnetz-Politik nachhören. Ähm aber es ist natürlich klar, ne? Also dieser dieser Markt ist ähm.
Ist auf eine natürlich möchtest du musst du eine Funktionsgarantie für dein, für deine Exploits geben. Weil wenn du die ähm,
wenn du die verkaufst, könntest du dich ja trotzdem noch öffentlich hinstellen und sie nachher reporten. Und dann hast du,
Also du musst ja eine gewisse äh eine gewisse Garantie da geben,
Dass diese Sachen nicht bekannt werden. Und das ist natürlich eine Wette gegen die Zukunft.
Aber das heißt ja im Prinzip, dass sie gar nicht viele Kunden haben können für dieses Abo, weil wenn sie das auch nur zweien verkaufen, diese Information, dann widerspricht sich ja diese Garantie schon mal selber. Also das passt gerade für mich alles nicht so richtig zusammen.
Das, was du da äh was der das BSI-Abo, was das BSI Ding, was äh,
Das Abo bei wupen, was das BSI da hatte, bezog sich im Zweifelsfall nicht auf direkte, fertige Webiniste, wie man es so schön nennt. So, du hast ja immer noch mal den Unterschied zwischen einer Schwachstelle.
Und ähm dem Explod dafür.
Ja? Und es gab offenbar, das ist auch schon länger bekannt, dass das BSI äh und andere ähm diesen Dienst in Anspruch nehmen. Das ist quasi so ein Infodienst.
Also nicht den Dienst um Webiniz, Software, sondern nur um die Information, dass solche Sicherheitslücken vorliegen und wo man sie dann besser zu schließen habe. Ja, aber wäre natürlich,
äh jemanden äh verkauft und dafür eine Garantie gibt, hat er natürlich auch kein Interesse, dieselbe Information an andere wiederum zu verkaufen.
Das ist die äh das ist die Frage,
da die ich auch nicht, die ich nicht beantworten kann. Ähm ich vermute, dass du einfach, äh dass das natürlich preislich geregelt wird, ne, wenn du sagst, okay, ich möchte einen äh Zero Day haben, um was weiß ich, den
einen Chrome Browser aufzumachen und remote Code Execution zu bekommen, im Drive-Buy. Das ist halt, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich so eine,
was weiß ich, viertel bis halbe Million äh US-Dollar im Moment wert. Wer jetzt so so grobe, meine grobe Schätzung ohne da genau informiert zu sein, weil Crow mit der bestgeschützte und bestgebox für Browser ist.
Mhm.
Musst du dann eben preislich äh in die Höhe gehen, wenn du sagst, du willst das auch noch exklusiv haben.
Das wäre jetzt so, ich meine, Märkte funktionieren halt so, wie sie für alle Akteure sinnvoll sind,
Und wenn du sagst, hier ist das egal, du willst irgendwie deine was weiß ich, äh,
zweistellige Anzahl Opfer innerhalb der nächsten Monate damit infizieren, dann kannst du halt auch sagen, ja gut, den brauche ich nicht exklusiv. So, den können von mir aus auch andere nutzen. Hauptsache, der landet nicht bei äh bei Google im Upstream.
Mit anderen Worten, wir wissen nicht so ganz genau, von welcher Art,
Vertrag, den es BSI hatte, nun wirklich wahr und was.
Informationsding gehabt, die haben keine, dass.
Nicht exklusiv sozusagen.
Nein, das, das ist das, das es gibt, das das haben wir aber auch hier schon besprochen, das ist äh von denen quasi so ein Informationsabo gibt. Und das hatte das BSi.
Komm mal ganz kurz das.
Notwendig.
Organisation Zero Day Attack. Das ist eigentlich lustig, ne? Die verkaufen einerseits die Zero Days und andererseits den Schutz dagegen. Die sind echt ganz gut, die.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen, als würdest du so Waffen verkaufen, unschusssichere Westen.
Genau. Das ist echt eine das wäre das wäre ja ein Witz, ne? Oder wenn du halt einfach mal nach Saudi Arabien Panzer verkaufen würdest oder so.
Bitte sowas tun.
Also BSI hatte das äh Fred Protection Programm. Wir reden aber eigentlich, das war die Meldung,
vom BND und der BND möchte wirkliche ähm wirkliche kaufen und nicht irgendwie zum Schutz, sondern die möchten damit aktiv angreifen,
nämlich um SSL äh verschlüsselte Verbindungen zu umgehen. Und so wie sich das hier anhört, ähm ist das im Prinzip das, was sich äh Quellen-PKÜ nennt, ne?
Zwei Rechner. Ähm zwischen denen geht AfD wird eine SSL geschützte äh Verbindung aufgebaut. Ähm wir haben natürlich Möglichkeiten,
als äh State level actor.
Da ein Mennende Mittelangriff zu machen. Aber wenn ähm.
Wenn die Leute Browser wie zum Beispiel äh Google Chrome nutzen, der immer mehr äh darauf achtet, wie Zertifikate aussehen äh oder vielleicht zum Beispiel so Surtpinning ähm,
Plug-ins nutzen, also Plug-ins, die dich darüber warnen, wenn sich das Sicherheitszertifikat der Seite ändert.
Bewertung vorzunehmen, also wenn zum Beispiel siehst, das alte Zertifikat,
in der nächsten Woche abgelaufen, ähm dann ist das natürlich in Ordnung
dass dass es jetzt ein neues gibt. Es gibt auch
bestimmte äh Plug-ins, ähm die zum Beispiel die ganze Zeit einfach nur die Zertifikatsfinger-Prince in so einer,
Cloudlösungen, Reporten, um dich dann davor zu warnen, wenn du ein anderes Zertifikat siehst als der Rest der Welt,
der gezielte Angriff auf ähm auf den Rechner.
Deiner Zielperson, sodass du die
vor dem Entstehen der Verschlüsselung schon abgreift. Da haben wir's halt klassische Staatstrojaner Quellen TKÜ diese gesamte Geschichte. Äh verbirgt sich dahinter. Ja, das schreiben sie nur offenbar in äh in ihrer Motivation. Ähm
Schreiben sie eben, dass sie da äh,
diese gefährliche Verschlüsselung umgehen wollen. Warum ist das so spannend? Viereinhalb Millionen ist natürlich schon ein Betrag, da kannst du ein paar Explods verkaufen.
Und das Problem an dieser ganzen Geschichte ist natürlich der äh das, dass du,
dafür in Kauf nimmst und dir sogar garantieren lässt von deinem Anbieter, dass diese Sicherheitslücken weiterhin bestehen,
und du nicht garantieren kannst, dass du der Einzige bist, der den Zugriff darauf hat,
Kriminelle sie schon seit Jahren ausnutzen und du auch nichts davon weißt. Das heißt, du nimmst,
mit diesem Betrag, den du ausgibst und dieser Entscheidung,
diese Sicherheitslücke niemanden zu informieren, sondern sie auszunutzen,
in Kauf, dass andere dies auch tun,
und dass alle Nutzer dieser Software diesem Risiko ausgesetzt bleiben. Und das heißt, dass du natürlich aktiv gegen,
die Sicherheit der äh Computerinfrastruktur der Welt und deines deiner eigenen Bürger arbeitest.
Ist mir egal, ob das jetzt jeder tut, aber es ist natürlich vollständig falsch.
Aktiv sich daran zu beteiligen, dass Computersysteme unsicher bleiben. Und das ist das, was da,
was mit einer solchen Ausgabe gemacht wird. Nicht nur das, es wird nicht nur darauf hingearbeitet, dass Computersysteme ähm,
äh unsicher bleiben, sondern es wird darauf hingearbeitet, dass Menschen, die in der Lage sind, Computersysteme auf ihre Sicherheit zu prüfen, finanzielle Anreize haben
nicht zu einer Verbesserung der Situation beizutragen, sondern zu versuchen, diese Explods irgendwie zu verscherbeln. Das heißt, wenn das so weitergeht,
und wir nicht nennenswerte finanzielle,
dann müssen wir davon ausgehen, dass Sicherheitslücken in Zukunft nur noch äh gehandelt werden und nur noch an Geheimdienste gegeben werden und kein Mensch mehr eine Motivation verspürt, beziehungsweise kein Mensch mehr die Ressourcen aufbringen kann,
ähm aktiv einfach eine Verbesserung des Sicherheitszustands zu arbeiten.
Du kannst irgendwie, natürlich kriegst du als Sicherheitsprüfer vernünftige Tagessätze, wenn du für,
für bestimmte Unternehmen arbeitest und dann dann machst oder sonst was. Die Realität sieht aber so aus, wenn ich da jetzt mal ähm.
Diese SSL-Lücken zum, als Beispiel nehmen darf, ne? Also,
den ja? Der war ja irgendwie jahrelang.
Verbreitet auf allen Rechnersystemen. Da sind große Unternehmen äh in Deutschland, waren natürlich auch Facted von Hartlead, ja? Banken zum Beispiel,
deren gesamtes Sicherheitskonzept mit dieser Online-Banking äh Geschichte basiert darauf, dass keiner,
deine Kommunikation mit der Bank abhören kann, ja? Wenn wenn beziehungsweise,
nur äh abhören, sondern zum Beispiel auch im Rahmen eines Mittelangriffs manipulieren kann, ne, was ja aufgrund der Zweitfaktor-Authentifizierung dann auch.
Es bricht zusammen in dem Moment, wo SSL zusammenbricht, kann ich äh von deinem Konto Geld überweisen. Ja, aber locker mit der Mütze.
Nö. Na, da gibt's aber dann immer noch die Wandheim-Passworts.
Also es äh es gibt das Einzige, was das Einzige, was es sinnvoll verhindert, ist ähm,
diese Flickercourt-Generatoren, weil die dir nochmal eine zweite Möglichkeit geben, auf dem Flicker-Code-Generator nachzusehen, welche Überweisung du da gerade autorisierst.
Aber das hast, das benutzt du ja gar nicht.
Flickercode.
Ja
Ja, siehst du. Das ist so ein so eine Art QR-Code, ähm Lesegerät, was du an dem Bildschirm hältst,
deine EC-Karte drinsteckt und das zeigt dir dann äh auf dem Display an,
für die Überweisung folgenden Betrages auf folgendes Konto ähm.
Gibst du jetzt diesen äh äh diese Tannen ein.
Das ist das einzige System, was nennenswerten Schutz vorm Mittelangriff,
im Banking bringt. Ähm.
Diese SMS-Geschichten kannst du natürlich in einer Pfeife rauchen aus offensichtlichen Gründen. Ähm.
Das Onlinebanking ist selbstverständlich die äh die sichere Kommunikation, die verschlüsselte Kommunikation und vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation zwischen deinem Clint und äh diesem äh und dem Banking-Server. So. Die waren also quasi.
Jahrelang äh betroffen von? Keiner von denen hat offensichtlich einfach mal ein paar hundert äh Tausend in die Hand genommen, um mein Audit,
von Open SSL durchführen zu lassen, ja?
Und die saßen in der Bank, also die hätten das Geld durchaus mal gehabt, ja, aber die haben quasi nicht diese diese Minimalinvestitionen,
Wenn du jetzt ähm eine solche eine solche Lücke findest, wie es dann den Leuten von und dem Forscherteam von Google relativ zeitgleich gelungen ist
äh bei äh bei da hättest du natürlich sehr, sehr viel besseres Geld mitmachen können,
Direkt, wenn du das an an andere Leute verkauft hättest, ja? Und das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal das Ausmaß. Ich weiß nicht, was das was so eine kann nur schwer schätzen, was so ein äh.
Auf diesem Markt gebracht hätte, ja? Das ist, das wäre aber eine eine enorme Summe gewesen.
Angriff auf SSL. Zivoday, ja? Ähm so, aber das heißt, selbst die sind im Moment nicht äh motiviert,
ihre eigene Sicherheitslösung, die sie sich da anschauen, mal auf auf Herz und Nieren zu prüfen, beziehungsweise, seitdem sie jetzt diese Sache hatten, ändert sich dann natürlich was, ne? So, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt aber diese viereinhalb Millionen Euro nehme
und statt sie in Sicherheitslücken zu investieren und da rein, dass diese erhalten bleiben,
Ähm und ich nehme sie stattdessen und gebe sie einfach mal für Audits von sicherheitsrelevanter Open Source Software aus,
dann habe ich natürlich meinem mein Bürgern äh eine enorme einen enormen Dienst erwiesen,
Überleg mal, was du für viereinhalb Millionen alles auditieren lassen könntest.
Und dann hättest du als.
Kennen die Preise nicht.
Naja, so ein äh was weiß ich, rechne irgendwas zwischen achthundert und tausendzweihundert Euro Tagessatz.
Oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr, kommt drauf an.
So einen Auditor oder kannst du ja tausend Möglichkeiten nehmen.
Na gut, gut, das hat ja noch nichts über die Produktivität äh aus, also was da jetzt sozusagen an so einem Tag,
Schnitt du auch bei rumkommt.
Ja, es kommt halt drauf an, ne? Aber wie viel du halt auch für den Tag bezahlst. Nein, das Entscheidende wäre natürlich mit dem Geld, könntest würdest du ja mehrere Teams drauf loslassen,
äh und du würdest natürlich irgendwie versuchen, deren deren Bezahlung auf eine Weise zu regeln, äh dass sie erfolgsabhängig ist, ne?
Auch sehr interessant finde, ist das Ausloben von Back Bountys
Das heißt, du setzt im Prinzip Kopfgelder aus auf äh auf Sicherheitslücken
und das findet mir in der Software eine Remote Code Executionlücke oder eine eine Lücke, die es mir ermöglicht, da die verschlüsselte Verbindung ähm,
ähm aktiv oder passiv irgendwie zu unterwandern. Das heißt, du definierst einfach das das Angriffsszenario mit anderen Worten, das Risikoszenario
Den Angriff, vor dem du dich am meisten fürchtest und sagst, okay,
und ähm dafür loben wir aus, was weiß ich, Betrag X.
Ähm und dann,
Zweifelsfall, wenn keiner was findet, muss er auch nicht bezahlen, ne?
Nachteil ist, dass diese Backbounties in der Regel immer noch unter dem äh unter diesem Zero Day äh Preis liegen. Wir hatten da auch schon mal drüber gesprochen.
Äh das nämlich genau wupen. Ja diese Wettbewerbe ausnutzt, hingeht, ihre Exploits demonstriert,
Und dann von der Bühne geht und sagt, nee, wir sagen euch aber nicht, wie es geht. Wir danken euch einfach nur für die Aufmerksamkeit,
ihr jetzt gerade in die Welt der Welt gezeigt habt, dass wir es können,
Aber für die sechzigtausend, die uns bietet, äh sagen wir euch nicht, wie was gemacht haben, weil,
bei unseren Kunden kriegen wir halt 'ne viertel Million oder so und das ist jetzt könnt ihr die sechzigtausend behalten na?
Also das ist ähm.
Beziehungsweise nicht alles, was man findet, muss man jetzt veröffentlichen und so weiter. Ja, mehr haben wir nicht gefunden und das sind nochmal so zwei, drei kleine Goldstücke bei äh herabgefallen sind, auch schon mal vorbezahlt. Ja, das ist echt alles eine ganz furchtbare Geschichte.
Und so, das ist halt, das sind wirklich jetzt einfach, ich versuche das ja grade auch einfach nur über Markt äh Mechanismen zu erklären, ne.
Da setzt du halt mit so einer Investition ähm absolut falsche falsche, das falsche Zeichen.
Ja, dann haben sie noch ein paar andere Sachen, in die sie investieren möchten. Ähm das war dann bei der,
der Tagesschau. Äh die hatte da noch ein bisschen was zu gezeigt. Da scheint also ähm.
Irgendjemand gerade ähm,
Wissen darüber zu haben, was wie der BND so für die nächsten Jahre plant und oder mehrere Journalisten scheinen das gerade auszuweiten,
auszuweiden und die Menschen darüber in Kenntnis zu setzen. Interessant ist natürlich,
Warte mal, ich suche mal hier was, was sie was sie noch so alles ausgeben wollten. Ähm,
wollen sie achtundzwanzig Millionen haben,
Ähm bis jetzt ist das noch nicht bewilligt. Dann haben sie ein Programm namens Nitti Detza. Äh.
Mit dem sie eben in Zukunft auch äh weiterhin äh ATTPS und SSL irgendwie brechen wollen.
Also das waren, das war's, glaube ich. Also sie haben ja immer so komische ähm Namen. Ein Name ist äh.
Ja, damit wollen sie Zugriff auf Vermittlungsanlagen sichern im Ausland,
und ähm da kommst du überleg mal, Zugriff auf Telekommunikationsanlagen, ne? BND ist ja ein Auslandsgeheimnis, das äh Geheimdienst nicht auch das Geheimnis. Die wollen natürlich.
Im Außen, im Prinzip genau das machen, worüber wir uns gerade hier in Deutschland immer noch aufregen, dass es die Amerikaner tun, ne? Dass sie also Infrastruktur äh Kommunikationsinfrastruktur im Ausland infiltrieren. Wieper äh,
Da wollen sie äh IP,
und Metadaten besser erfassen können. Achtunddreißig Millionen Euro ausgeben bis zweitausendzwanzig.
Wo steckst du das grad nach?
Ähm das ist der, warte, das ist hier bei der Tagesschau. Den Link hatte ich nicht im Pad.
Und man sieht da natürlich ihre sorry, man sieht da natürlich ihre Bemühungen, sage ich mal, international,
konkurrenzfähig zu sein gegenüber diesen anderen Geheimdiensten.
Denkst du, dass sie das schaffen? Also konkurrenzfähig äh zu sein.
Naja, sie scheinen ja auch so viel also im Moment ist
ist ja, glaube ich, noch immer der vorliegende Skandal, dass sie gar nicht konkurrieren, sondern äh kollaborieren, ne. Ähm.
Insofern kann man das, glaube ich, dieses, diesen Begriff Konkurrenzfähigkeit äh da ist wahrscheinlich ähm Unabhängigkeit der äh,
der bessere Begriff für das was sie wirklich anstreben.
Ich find's erstaunlich und erschreckend, dass sowas ja.
Ich hätte halt gedacht, dass sowas nicht so.
Passieren würde in diesem in dieser kurzen Zeit immer noch nach den äh Snowen-Enthüllungen, ne. Das sind das sind immer eigentlich die alarmierenden Signale äh die solche ähm.
Enthüllung oder solche Berichte äh für für mich darstellen.
Am Ende macht das so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob sich eigentlich da gar nichts ändert.
Was meinst du mit gar nichts ändert?
An den Gepflogenheiten des äh der Geheimdienste. Also dass sie da einfach weitgehend äh unbeeindruckt von sind und ja, einfach weitermachen.
Und das ist äh ist wirklich erschreckend und gefährlich, ne? Also ich bin, ich bin da wirklich sehr äh.
Emotional investiert.
Nee, äh ich bin da wirklich sehr enttäuscht halt auch, ne, dass äh.
Ich habe das ja schon mal auch hier in einer Sendung gesagt. Wir diese ganze diese ganze Snowden-Sache,
die gab's, die gibt's nur einmal, ne? Diese Aufmerksamkeit die es dafür gibt. Und wenn.
Wenn der Drops jetzt einmal gelutscht ist und sich nichts geändert hat.
Dann ist das so und zwar für ziemlich lange Zeit. Weißt du, was ich meine? Das ist dann so wie,
dafür habe ich ja immer Sorge, dass irgendwann in in vierzig Jahren in den Geschichtsbüchern steht ja
war damals ein großer Skandal, da haben sich die Bürgerrechtler gegen gewehrt, das kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen,
Ja, weißt du so? Aber damals war das wirklich was Neues und da haben die Menschen, haben die Menschen vor dem Untergang äh der Demokratie gewarnt, der dann gar nicht eingetreten ist. Äh weißt du so? Denn äh also,
in diese Richtung,
Sache, die ich an diesen Enthüllungen oder an diesen Feststellungen bei diesem BND hier ganz interessant finde, ist, dass sie,
Die Preise dazu sagen, was der BND da investieren möchte, in welchen Bereichen, ja? Und ähm das erlaubt natürlich auch ein bisschen den Rückschluss auf ihre momentanen Fähigkeiten.
Ja, wenn du jetzt hier in diese in diese Tagesschauberichte schaust, ähm.
Viereinhalb Millionen für Zero Days ist jetzt auch nicht so viel, ne?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Kennen die Preise nicht. Wenn du das sagst.
Ja, aber das heißt, dass fangen, wenn du von null anfängst, dann musst du mehr ausgeben. Dann müsstest du auch noch Personal dazu haben, was sie am Ende einsetzen soll und so, ne? Ähm.
Beobachtung von sozialen Netzwerken. Dafür haben wir ja schon mal berichtet. Da wollen sie jetzt halten, steht jetzt hier, wollen sie einen Prototypen starten?
Ja, das heißt, wenn sie dann Prototypen starten, das heißt natürlich was anderes, als äh wenn wenn ein wenn ein Projekt heißt, äh äh Fähigkeiten ausbauen oder erhalten. Ne, und dann irgendwie nur ein bisschen Geld dran steht.
Naja, also der BND.
Wollen wir mal voranschreiten.
Belächelt. Ja, gerne. Ähm.
Denn wir haben ja auch eine Diskussion, die schon ein bisschen länger.
Ein bisschen länger eigentlich schon geführt wird, ohne dass wir die bisher so richtig aufgegriffen hätten,
immer so ein bisschen hin und her ging, nämlich
um die PKW-Maut, die auch eigentlich überhaupt gar keine wirklich neue Diskussion ist, weil schon seit
LKW-Maut beziehungsweise halt das Mautsystem überhaupt in Deutschland errichtet wurde vor mittlerweile, weiß gar nicht
steht das Zeug schon, zehn Jahre jetzt. Ähm,
Gab's ja eigentlich schon immer aus dem Datenschutznetz politischen Lager eigentlich die Warnung, dass in dem Moment, wo man sich halt so ein technisches Überwachungssystem einfallen lässt, diese ist natürlich dann auch,
äh irgendwann mal zu einer Vollüberwachung,
verwendet ähm werden kann. Das ist,
Besondere war für die Art und Weise, wie das Mautsystem in Deutschland funktioniert,
Erfassung erfolgt ja über das Scan von Nummernschildern.
Und obwohl die Maut für,
Die Benutzung von Autobahnen und ich glaube mittlerweile teilweise auch schon ausgewählten Bundesstraßen. Ähm,
äh Lastwagen gedacht ist, werden natürlich alle Fahrzeuge zunächst einmal,
betrachtet, sprich gescannt die Kameras, die oben in diesen schönen Mautbrücken angebracht sind, die,
nicht erstmal ist das ein Lastwagen, sondern die schauen halt einfach,
Nummernschild scannen dieses Nummernschild und dann geht,
quasi die vollständige Information, jedes, jeder einzelnen vorbeifahrt,
einzelnen registrierten Fahrzeugs in das System. Und dort wird dann halt überprüft, handelt es sich bei diesem Registrierten Fahrzeug um einen Lastwagen, der hier entsprechend gebührenpflichtig wäre
oder ist und dann nur, wenn das nicht so ist, wird diese Information, na ja, gelöscht.
Nun ist das hier mit dem Löschen von Daten so eine Sache, ja? Also man kann,
natürlich schon ein System bauen, wo solche Daten ähm,
einerseits durch Fehler und eben auch durch viele andere Seiten Effekte
Ist das halt so eine Sache. Und vor allem in dem Moment, wo die politischen Begehrlichkeiten entstehen, na ja, man könnte ja auch mal alles angucken, weil wir haben ja hier irgendwie Terroristen und böse Menschen und Kinderschänder und
was nicht alles, Bankräuber und Pipapo. Äh nicht wahr? Also Leute, die uns bedrohen, die es ja auch gibt.
Ähm ja, die könnte man ja nun wunderbar eben dadurch dann auch scannen, wenn wir sowieso schon überall scannen,
Nummernschild scannen, ist ja auch sehr beliebt in Bayern
ich weiß gar nicht, was da so der letzte Stand ist. Ich glaube, wir hatten auch mal darüber berichtet. Es gab so verschiedene Gerichtsurteile, die das äh mehr oder weniger durchgewunken haben
da stellt sich die Polizei halt dann auch gerne mal ein Tag irgendwo hin und scannt dann mal so alles, was so vorbeifährt, so nach dem Motto,
dass der Geier was vorbeikommt. Vielleicht finden wir ja mal irgendjemanden, der gerade gesucht wird. Und,
Nun ist nun seit längerem, seit,
eigentlich seit die neue Bundesregierung so im Amt ist. Äh ist eine der,
vornehmlichen Themen von Herrn,
Dobrindt, wir erinnern uns, eins der drei Fragezeichen im deutschen Internetministeriums Hickhack
ähm äh sein Plan ist halt auch dann mal eine PKW-Maut einzurichten, denn Herr Dobrindt ist ja bei der CSU und die CSU hat ja nun im,
dann,
Im Wahlkampf kräftig getönt,
man müsse ja nun mal endlich mal hier die Ausländer für die Benutzung der deutschen
Genau, die fahren jetzt die Straßen kaputt.
Ganz schlimm ist das.
Wir gehen ja sehr pfleglich damit um, aber auch ausländische Reifen und so, überhaupt alles total gefährlich. Äh das Ganze ist jetzt durch einen etwas merkwürdiges
Politfeld gegangen, unter anderem da mussten wir jetzt nochmal,
helfen, weil ich nicht genau weiß, wie das eigentlich ausgegangen ist. Ging das ja auch durch europäische Gremien,
soweit ich mich entsinne.
Unter bestimmten Rahmenbedingungen, so eine Regelung durchaus ermöglicht haben. Also es war ja immer so die ähm Erwartungshaltung, dass das auf europäischer Ebene komplett eingesackt wird,
Ich weiß aber jetzt gerade nicht, wie das Ergebnis das europäische Ergebnis aussah.
Das kann ich dir leider auch nicht sagen, weil ich mich mit äh PKW äh Maut
irgendwie überhaupt nicht auseinandergesetzt habe. Das halte ich für.
Also da habe ich ähm das habe ich noch nicht, habe ich, weiß ich nicht,
aber wenn das heute noch weiter diskutiert wird, dann wurde es offensichtlich von der EU nicht irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Nicht vollständig.
Also ich bin da nicht der äh bin da jetzt also aus der betroffenen Autofahrerperspektive äh habe ich da nicht. Ähm.
Das Problem ist natürlich hier grundsätzlich, dass eben solche Mautsysteme,
hohes Missbrauchspotential haben, weil in dem Moment, wo man einen vollautomatisches System,
was grundsätzlich schon mal alles kennen.
Das haben wir bereits, ja, also die PKW-Maut in dem Sinne verschärft jetzt auch erstmal gar nichts, außer, dass die legal gescannte Größenordnung natürlich,
Also von Fahrzeugen,
enorm ansteigen würden, das heißt in dem Moment wäre die Software nicht gezwungen, auf dem frühestmöglichen Weg, die Daten zu vergessen, sondern es wäre sozusagen Teil des des Retainments. Ähm unter anderem gab's dann äh
weil's ja dann Bedenken gibt natürlich auch was soforts Datenspeicherung so verschiedene Ansätze und Erklärungen, warum denn äh Daten überhaupt lange vorgehalten werden müssen. Da gab's dann zum Beispiel so eine dreizehnmonatige ähm,
Zeit, die halt dort angekündigt wurde in diesen Plänen. Und die Argumentation war, na ja,
Monate bräuchte man halt, weil äh es könnte ja dann nach zwölf Monaten sein, dass jemand, der überhaupt nicht auf der Autobahn gefahren ist, äh sein Geld zurück haben will.
Also er muss ja dann sozusagen belegen können, dass er nicht gefahren ist,
und dazu muss man dann eben die Daten eben auch entsprechend zwölf Monate vorhalten, damit man dann diesen Antrag dann auch entsprechend äh.
Starten kann. Also es ist.
Und da hat der Zirkus sofort gesagt, äh der scheidende BKA-Chef oh!
Das ist ja eine ganz tolle Idee.
Das ist gut, da wollen wir dann auch mal kurz reingucken bei der Gelegenheit. Da hat sich aber dann ja der Herr Dobrindt verwehrt. Hat er, gesagt, nee.
Sojan und ich. Ich will wirklich nur das Geld.
Er hat er hat nämlich, er hat nämlich die strengsten Datenschutzbestimmungen, die er kennt.
Mhm. Ja, musst du gucken, weil musst du gucken, was er da hat.
Also die ähm die Sache ist natürlich
klar hier. Also im Moment, das haben wir auch bei der LKW-Maut auch gehabt, dass da irgendwie lange äh rumgeturnt wurde. Ja, das äh wird niemals irgendwie äh als Kennzeichen voll Überwachungssystem genutzt, auf deutsch-n,
Autobahn.
Auch PKW-Maut an sich wäre ja auch überhaupt nichts, was Angela Merkel auch nur ansatzweise mal äh unterbringen wollen.
Jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, dass die ähm also wenn man jetzt mal sagt, man man will so eine Maut haben,
dann ist es natürlich, wie ich jetzt nun mal auch wenigstens die Vorteile darstellen. Ähm.
Wenn das wirklich über Kennzeichenerfassung machst,
Also ich glaube, die äh die Stadt London macht das jetzt zum Beispiel so, da kommst du ja in den Innenstadtbereich, der ist ja auch mordpflichtig
machen seit Kennzeichenerfassung und wenn sie da ein Kennzeichen ähm,
feststellen, was nicht diese diese
Gebühr bezahlt hat, ne, dann wird halt automatisch Halterfeststellung kriegst du irgendwie einen Strafzettel nach Hause, ne. Ähm die.
Wenn du jetzt überlegst, okay, du möchtest das so, so einfach wie möglich für die Nutzer haben, diese Abrechnung. Ja, und Leute können ähm,
vierzehn Tage, zweiundzwanzig Euro oder sowas im Kopf,
ähm und du kannst halt quasi ein du musst brauchst einfach nur das
Kennzeichen zu registrieren. Das heißt, du gehst auf irgendeine Internetseite, sagst
Ich möchte nächstes äh nächste Woche Urlaub in Deutschland machen, von dann bis dann. Bin sechs Tage im Land, ich äh kaufe das Zehn-Tagesticket äh und zwar für diesen Zeitraum mit folgenden Kennzeichen gut ist.
Ja, kannst du über Kreditkarte zahlen, äh fährst über die Grenze und alles ist gut.
Mhm.
Keiner keiner hält dich an an der Grenzstation du musst hier nicht irgendeine Vignette in die Karre kleben, die du nicht haben willst es gibt schön abgestufte Angebote für die Dauer der Zeit äh und gleichzeitig hast du eine Möglichkeit, das eben auch ordentlich zu kontrollieren
Ähm denn,
Die Sorge ist natürlich der Gemeinden Naupreller,
Also wenn da jetzt Vignetten äh machst, dann könnte es ja sein, dass die Leute anfangen, die zu fälschen,
Abgesehen davon kannst du müsstest du deine Polizei äh
Kräfte und Ordnungsamtkräfte damit belasten. Jetzt noch auf noch eine Plakette zu gucken, ne, was äh müssen ja schon auf die Feinstaubplaketten gucken
Das machen sie übrigens nur beim Parken, ne, also äh die das machen, das macht das Ordnungsamt die Parkscheine kontrollieren. Das nur so als kleiner Hinweis, wenn man mal irgendwie seinen alten
noch nicht ganz Oldtimer äh ohne Partikelfilter irgendwo äh.
Ja, aber allgemeine Verkehrskontrolle ist ja doch sehr äh selten, ja. Da kannst du aber auch immer sagen, da kommst du übrigens aus der Nummer raus, wenn du sagst, du fährst eh gerade zur Werkstatt, um Partikelfilter nachrüsten zu lassen,
Samstag nachts nicht mit einer Flasche Bier in der Hand, aber sonst kommst du mit der Nummer vielleicht mal durch.
Für den Rest ist die Parkraumstraße hier sozusagen zuständig.
Das hast du jetzt, äh, Stasi genannt. Ich finde das ja ein äh, finde das ja ausgerechnet am zehnten November, ey. Wenn das,
gehört hätte, was du gerade gesagt hast, Tim, dann wäre aber was los, du.
Ja wieso ist denn diese Herren und Damen die halt hier immer in so auffälligen Anoraks irgendwie durch die Straßen gehen und immer rumstehen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, so Berufswunsch, Ordnungsamt, das ist halt auch so ein kann ich ja doch nicht verstehen, ne. Aber gibt's.
Müssen wir uns jetzt nicht so äußern.
Gibt's. Ähm wobei das, glaube ich, so ist, dass die ähm.
Andere Methoden haben in der Tat äh einfach aus für die für die Nutzer.
Einfach sehr große Widrigkeiten und sind äh nicht so engmaschig in in der in der Erfassungsmöglichkeit, ne? So, aber natürlich hast du das Problem,
Du dir da jetzt offensichtlich irgendwelche Mautbrücken hinstellen willst, dann wird's ja wahrscheinlich noch ein paar mehr. Die sind ja noch relativ selten, dieser LKW-Maut,
finde ich. Ja, also ich weiß, ich fahre so wenig Auto.
Ich hoffe Autobahn.
Ja klar, in der Stadt stehen die nicht. So, dann hast du diese ganze Infrastruktur und fotografierst,
Einfach mal auf den Hauptverkehrsadern deines Landes jedes Scheiß Kennzeichen jeden Tag, an jeder Stelle, ja, oder an auf jeder Autobahn. Das heißt, du hast irgendwann halt das Verkehrsbewegungsprofil im Prinzip,
aller Menschen, die sich in dem Land irgendwie nennenswert bewegen.
Naja, die mit der Bahn fahren zahlen mit schön mit ihrer Kreditkarte. Bahn gehört hier ohnehin.
Ja, ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht ist es.
Auch ein wenig Sturm im Wasserglas, ja, also noch vor einiger Zeit mag ja äh wir wissen immer, wo dein Auto ist, durchaus ein Aspekt gewesen sein, nur.
Uns auch klar, wir leben in einer Zeit, wo der jeder Aufenthalt, jeder einzelnen Person, die ein Mobiltelefon besitzt und die Anzahl von Personen, die ein Mobiltelefon besitzt,
Verhältnis zu den Personen, die ein Auto,
Angemeldet haben, ja? Also das ist das ist wirklich die entscheidende Zahl, weil da hast du potentiell jeden,
Potenziell, jeden, also zumindest fast alle. Und da hast du nicht nur Bewegungen auf Autobahnen oder auch mal auf einer Fernstraße, sondern hast jeden Aufenthaltsort,
jederzeit, immer, sofern das Telefon bei einem ist. Und.
Die Sache sich, dann kann man ja auch gleich
durch die Maut ein Überwachungspotential geschaffen wird und Begehrlichkeiten äh geweckt werden, die sicherlich auch da sind. Es kommt noch etwas hinzu.
Das ist jetzt erstmal äh grundsätzlich richtig, ja. Wie gesagt, ich bin da ähm,
persönlich auch nicht ganz so emotional, was jetzt diese, was jetzt diese Mautsachen angeht, aber ähm.
Das mit den mit den Mobilfunk äh Sachen, die du nennst, da
ob ich's jetzt normalerweise beim Mobilfunk sagen ja nicht tue, muss ich da aber trotzdem mal ein bisschen einschränken, was du darüber gesagt hast, denn selbst mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh sollten die ja nur bekommen, wo sich das Telefon zum Zeitpunkt einer Transaktion aufgehalten hat.
Ich trenne jetzt gerade die technische Begehrlichkeit, die es da gibt von dem, was da gerade erlaubt ist.
Also Mobilfunkanbieter machen, können das natürlich wunderbar. Die können,
haben, da gibt's sogar schöne äh grafische Softwares für mit so schönen Maps, Integrierung und.
Ja, wer sich schon immer mal gefragt hat, wo diese ganzen Staumeldungen herkommen, das kommt genau davon.
Zwar keine persönliche Auswertung, sondern in dem Fall halt eine anonyme oder hoffentlich anonyme Auswertung. Aber das ist im Prinzip genau das Handys, die sich in Autos über Straßen bewegen. Das ist das, was irgendwie sagt, hier ist gerade mehr Verkehr.
Ähm.
Ja. Aber das ist also ist natürlich das hatten wir glaube ich auch damals besprochen, dass O2 da jetzt sogar eine eigene Tochter ausgegliedert hat,
entsprechende Vermarktung vornimmt. Ähm.
Mit den Autos ist das natürlich so eine Sache. Ich meine, ist das eine, wenn du jetzt dir vorstellst,
einfach nur am Arsch bist. Ähm.
Sondern du bist irgendwie Berufspendler, du fährst da so durch die Gegend und es gibt einfach eine Datenbank, da steht einfach mal die letzten dreizehn Monate drin, wo du hingefahren bist, ja?
Grenze zu einem attraktiven Nachbarland wohnt, in dem ähm,
erhältlich sind.
Anderen legalen Voraus.
Zum Beispiel, ne? Leckeren Joghurt und so. Ja, das ist natürlich schon eine äh,
eine scheiß Sache, wenn du dann da irgendwie regelmäßig ins europäische Ausland äh fahren möchtest und mit der mit dem Wissen leben musst, ähm.
Ja also mit dir jetzt nix mehr machen.
Kommen halt auch so Hochrechnungen, ne, dann wirst du vielleicht irgendwann mal mit mit irgendwie einen Liter zu viel im Kofferraum von dem vom Zoll erwischt
ja? Und dann äh rechnen die hoch, wie viel Liter Flah du da gegessen hast und dass das irgendwie die zulässigen Höchstgrenzen überschritten hat,
Das sind schon einfach Scheißsachen, ja? Das sind einfach blöde äh,
Einschränkungen äh der Freiheit und,
oder was heißt Einschränkung? Es ist dieses der Effekt, der da immer da ist auf dem wir da Rücksicht nehmen müssen ist eben dieses,
Dein Verhalten ändert sich dadurch, dass du weißt, dass es eben überwacht wird,
und das ist halt immer, das ist ein Effekt, der ist einfach da, ja? Gibt auch nur wenige Menschen, die denen irgendwie noch ernsthaft in Frage stellen. Wobei, wenn man bei denen auch von jeder Form der Verhaltensänderung äh,
ja, kein jetzt nicht mehr mit rechnen muss. Ähm.
Aber ich fände das nicht besonders positives Gefühl.
Nö, ich auch nicht.
Und das jetzt irgendwie zu relativieren an Mobilfunk. Den kann ich wenigstens ausschalten. Ja, fahr mal mit einem ausgeschalteten Auto Flah kaufen.
Tja, dann musst du dein Nummernschild abhängen.
Genau aus der Nummer steht. Ja, kriegst du auch nur einen auf den Sack, ne.
Strafverfolger, dann jetzt sofort sagen, ah super, Datenbank wollt ihr mal, äh finde ich eine prima Idee. Macht mal schöne Datenbank, in schweren Ausnahmefällen übrigens. Äh würden wir dann auch gerne mal äh da reinschauen.
Ja, weil nur bei wirklich einen richtigen, bösen, dicken Verbrecher.
Nur bei wirklich schweren Ausnahmefällen, ja? So, ne, wie wir das schon kennen mit den schweren Ausnahmefällen vor.
Nur ab eins achtzig und so.
So und das ist das ist das Erschreckende an dieser Debatte ist, wie wie völlig seelenruhig da so ein Konzept vorgeschlagen wird mit einer mit einer wirklich signifikanten Datenerfassung
Für einen Großteil der Bundesbürger mit enormen Missbrauchspotential. Und wie völlig seelenruhig wir das hier zur Kenntnis nehmen, dass sofort,
irgendwelche Strafverfolgungsbehörden, Geheimdienste und hasse nicht gesehen,
Da wie selbstverständlich ihren Anspruch drauf anmelden und sich dann noch, ich meine, dieser Zirkel ist siebenundsechzig, der,
Zum Abschluss irgendwie sind die Frustration seiner der letzten zehn Jahre seiner Arbeit. Ich meine, du musst ins Ziel kümmern, ich habe den ja schon öfter mal reden hören, ne. Ähm,
begeht noch mit mit mit und spalt Gift und Galle auf die Datenschützer, ne? Und sieht hier irgendwie die die Welt in Flammen, Sodom und Gomorra, ne? Und er kann nichts tun, der arme Mann,
So, das ist das ist so seine Abschlussmessage, ne, dass wir irgendwie eine verqueren äh Datenschutzfundamentalismus in diesem Land haben,
uns hier die die Kriminellen äh die Häuser leerräumen oder was auch immer er da irgendwie als Bedrohungsszenario jetzt für sich empfindet, ne,
Und das eben zeigt mir, dass diese diese ganzen Snowden-Debatten, sorry.
Nicht die Frucht getragen haben, die man sich da irgendwann mal äh für hätte erhoffen können. Deswegen bin ich sauer.
Ja, nee, da musst du schon äh musst du schon die die Klassiker der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit äh auffahren, wenn du wirklich Aufmerksamkeit haben willst.
So, ne? Was gibt's noch irgendwie? Ob man nicht mit denen jetzt mal irgendwie da koaliert und äh sich dagegen irgendwie mal,
Ne?
Anlass dazu gäb's genug.
Freie Fahrt für freie Bürger, kann ich nur sagen.
Vor allem so ein Korruptionsfreier Verein wie der ADAC ist ja.
Ja komm ey, der ist doch auch irgendwie.
Wodka.
Mach mal eine Sondersendung im ZDF.
Äh wir schalten nach Europa, dort äh haben wir ja das vierte Fragezeichen, Herrn Öttinger, zuständig für,
wie er sagen würde, wie ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe. Und äh der äußert sich jetzt, nachdem er sich jetzt schon ein paar Tage mit diesem für ihn vollkommen neuen Thema beschäftigt hat.
Dann doch mit ganz äh interessanten Vorschlägen. Unter anderem hat er jetzt vorgeschlagen, na ja, man solle doch mal äh
auch mal was für die Netzbetreiber tun, die sind ja so verfolgt und ähm hätten ja so unglaubliche Probleme, die Investitionsbereitschaft zu zeigen, die man von ihnen gerne so erwartet
zum Beispiel, indem man ihnen einfach äh dabei hilft, die äh,
Zeiträume zu ja lang zu halten von von von verlängern brauchen wir ja gar nicht zu sprechen, sondern
bisher war die Diskussion, da macht er das vielleicht einzuschränken. Hörtinger möchte das also gerne verlängern, bis man eben einen neuen Anbieter wählen darf, äh,
wenn man sich mal irgendwann mal für einen entschieden hat, sprich so
diese Zwangslaufzeiten von Verträgen. Wir kennen das aus dem Mobilfunkbereich, äh subventioniertes Telefon, machen,
was wir mit ähm gehupfter Braue äh nur begleiten können, denn das ist nun wirklich nichts, was zu einem flexibleren digitalen Markt führen würde.
Nee, man muss mal, also das Flexibilität ist da ja noch das das kleinste Problem. Ähm die Mindest oder die die,
maximale Vertragsbindung in Europa ist, in diesem Fall vierundzwanzig Monate. Das erkennt man daran,
dass alle dir Verträge anbieten, mit vierundzwanzig Monaten Dauer, wenn sie längere dürften, würden sie natürlich sofort längere machen,
Und ähm man macht ja eigentlich immer die Erfahrung, dass,
Dein Tarif auch wirklich nach zwei Jahren? Nicht mehr so so günstig ist wie,
Ähm ja, es war beim Abschluss, ja. Das heißt, diese äh diese Periodenlänge äh.
Ich kriege gerade eine SMS, wie ich soll mir äh ein neues Tablett holen, um meinen Vertrag zu verlängern, den ich nämlich jetzt gekündigt habe.
Danke, danke ihr Freunde, Freunde des Freunde des äh des Bits.
Des liberalisierten Marktes.
Ja. So, das heißt, diese diese Dauer äh definiert wie schnell Anbieter ähm.
Die Preise senken. Ja, sie müssen ja die Preise immer senken oder mehr äh fürs gleiche Geld bieten,
Ja, weil sie im hart umkämpften Markt sind, müssen sich immer so ein bisschen gegenseitig unterbiegen. Halten sich aber natürlich auch diesen Konkurrenzkampf so ein bisschen vom Leib. Da gibt's also ja ganz offenkundig,
so gut selbstverständlich, meine zahlst heute noch für eine SMS Geld, ja? Für hundertvierzig Bite, die du irgendwie da mal so halbwegs irgendwo langschiebst. Ja, da da nehmen die heute noch Geld für.
Das ist irgendwie, also muss dir mal vorstellen, das sind ist ein Witz.
Das teuerste Bit auf jeden Fall aller Zeiten.
Und ähm der Preis hat sich ähm.
Eingepegelt. Ich glaube, das ist immer noch bei um die zwanzig Cent oder so, ne? Also gibt dann immer oder fünf Euro kostet eine SMS, Flatrate oder so, ich mache kein SMS, ich finde das doof. Ich mache ich mache billig Bits. Ich bin ja auch beim billigen Provider.
Aber ähm so, wenn jetzt diese, wenn du sagst, okay, ihr könnt die Kunden in Zukunft drei Jahre binden, dann wird das
entsprechend sofort dazu führen, dass sich eben dieser, diese Preissenkungskurve oder Leistungs Leistungs fürs Gleiche, das das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis, was dir so einen Anbieter bietet, wird sich automatisch verschlechtern.
Oder es wird nicht mehr so so zunehmen, wie es jetzt tut. Wenn du das kürzt,
wird sich das wird sich das natürlich äh äh wird diese Kurve steiler, ne, weil die kä,
Ähm.
Aus um um Investitionen in diesem Markt wirklich zu ermutigen. Möchtest du eigentlich die äh Maximaldauer auf ein Jahr runtersetzen?
Weil dann die Anbieter mal wirklich,
stärkeren Anreiz haben, jedes Jahr ihre Kunden glücklich zu machen, den jedes Jahr mehr zu bieten,
und um ihre Kunden zu kämpfen, ja? Ähm das zu verlängern, wird genau den gegenteiligen Effekt haben,
Und das ist erstaunlich, dass äh also es ist wieder mal erstaunlich, dass äh vorgibt, das nicht zu wissen,
Das weiß der doch. Und es ist ähm,
Wir müssen uns ohnehin mal äh eben über diesen Gedanken, über diese diesen Ansatz Gedanken machen, dass wir wollen, ob die Netzbetreiber wirklich ähm.
Bei anderer Infrastruktur ähm auch nicht unbedingt.
Außer Strom. Da kannst du dich natürlich du mit dem nicht dran verdienen. Öl, kannst dich automatieren nicht dran verdienen. Und Wasserkosten vermögen.
Ja, aber du, das ist genau der Effekt, den du nicht haben möchtest, wenn du sagst, du hast irgendwie, du möchtest international konkurrieren, du möchtest irgendwie eine Wirtschaftskrise überwinden? Dann möchtest du, dass die sich mit ihr, dass sie bitte schön,
Infrastruktur Wettrüsten machen,
um das Land endlich mal in die Gänge zu bekommen.
Ich glaube, da da dreht sich einfach diese gesamte Investitionsdiskussion auch so ein bisschen im Kreis so, ne? Auf der einen Seite schreien alle nach Internet und Bandbreite und wir sind ja jetzt hier irgendwie äh die digitale Zukunft. Das denkt da wahrscheinlich jeder Landkreis mittlerweile von sich.
Ähm war irgendwann mal in Stuttgart, da hingen dann auch irgendwelche Schilder mit. Ja, wir sind ja hier irgendwie das Silicon Valley, irgendwie äh Deutschlands, so.
Auch nicht ganz folgen in dem Moment, aber äh,
so diese Illusion, ja, das findet dann irgendeiner, das findet ihr dann total lustig und so, weil wir haben ja auch irgendwie schon drei Startups gezählt so, da geht ja richtig was ab,
Und natürlich gibt's dann halt so dieses Problem, dass irgendwie nachweislich ja irgendwie das mit dem Breitband, der war dann doch nicht so richtig funktioniert, ja? Du hast dann hier und da mal so,
war's äh entspanntere Situationen in so Städten wie äh Köln,
Städten wie Hannover, wo also sich zumindest so ein paar lokale Provider so bisschen auch eine eine Marktlandschaft geschafft haben und dann da der Telekom auch vor Ort
und den anderen größeren Unternehmen ähm ein bisschen Konkurrenz machen so im Bereich Hausanschluss. Ähm aber
Insgesamt wissen wir natürlich, sieht es halt ganz furchtbar aus.
Aber da schlägt doch auch die Telekom dann jedes Mal immer drauf, oder? Machen das dann, machen die das dann nicht unattraktiv und äh.
Ich bin jetzt über die Geschäftstaktiken, die da jetzt gerade äh abgehen, nicht so im Bilde. Ich sehe halt nur die Angebote, die da teilweise gemacht werden, die ähm,
Einzelkämpfer, aber die sind halt natürlich einfach keine Global Player, also schon gar also keine nationalen Player
Global Player schon gar nicht. So, jetzt äh stehen wir natürlich da, immer so mit dieser Forderung, na ja, warum gibt's denn bei bei Omar Bernsdorf irgendwie in ihrem,
Kuhdorf irgendwie kein Gigabit, so ja, das ist ja alles so furchtbar teuer. Und wir müssen ja dann irgendwie billige Glasfaserkabel durch Kanelle ziehen und es kann auch keiner bezahlen.
Was, wie wird das hier auch äh schon häufiger diskutiert haben, eigentlich Quatsch? Es gibt da sehr wohl äh sehr gute Ansätze, wie man das problemlos äh stemmen könnte an nur dieser Wunsch ist irgendwie nicht da oder der Wille ist nicht da, weil natürlich sich die äh großen
auch nicht aus dem Feld,
lassen wollen so. Also auf der einen Seite wollen sie nicht viel Geld in die Hand nehmen, auf der anderen Seite wollen sie aber auch keine Konkurrenz haben,
irgendwie so richtig
nicht zusammen
und äh deswegen stehen sie dann da so bettelnd und so, das ist ja alles so furchtbar teuer, gibt uns doch mal Geld. Dann kommt der Staat und sagt, naja, also Geld haben wir ja nun wirklich auch nicht unbedingt zu verteilen, was machen wir denn da? Und dann kommt es halt auf solche Sachen raus. Na ja, dann müsst ihr uns halt da noch ein bisschen mehr protektionieren, dann können wir auch ein bisschen mehr Geld machen, dann kriegt äh die Oma auch irgendwie ihr Gigabit.
Und es heißt natürlich, also die die Folge davon ist natürlich, ähm dass sie den Kunden mehr zumuten können,
Ja, also es ähm ein ein wichtiger Aspekt hier ist. Äh,
dass wir jetzt schon mit den vierundzwanzig Monaten nur darüber lachen können,
wenn, und das ist ja von der, von dieser Ex äh Partei, die es da gab,
diese ganze Netzneutralitätsfrage sicher über,
den Marktregeln entlasten wird. Mit anderen Worten über Konkurrenz und Abwanderung, ja? Und genau diese Effekte dämmst du dann natürlich auch ein, wenn du äh da eine höhere und längere Bindung äh machst. Das ist also wirklich,
Eine schlechte Entscheidung und ich bin wirklich oder ein eine schlechte Idee und ich,
eigentlich ähm so äh,
kein äh Markt äh liberaler unbedingt, äh aber in diesem Fall musst du auch wirklich sagen, dass das äh dass man da wirklich ähm mal die Kraft des Marktes entfesseln sollte. Was meinst du, wie viel die in
null Komma nix investieren würden, wenn du sagst, ab jetzt Mobilfunkvertrag kannst du alle drei Monate wechseln. So und zwar für,
zehn Euro Wechselgebühr, die deckeln wir nämlich, weil mehr kann das nicht kosten, eure die Rufnummernitnahme.
Ja? Was meinst du, was da los wäre? Die würden sofort würdest du auf jedem Dach,
äh die Techniker sehen, wie sie irgendwie LTE-Masten da dran schnallen, um bloß ihre Kunden zu behalten.
Also diese ganzen Telko-Unternehmen sind darauf,
die deren gesamte Jahrespläne sind auf diese Vertragslaufzeiten äh gerechnet. Meinst du, wenn die Telekom irgendwie ankündigt, wir drosseln hier die Leute, dass die nicht genau im Auge haben. Bei wie vielen Kunden innerhalb der nächsten zwei Monate die Verträge auslaufen.
Die dann, von denen sie dann halt vielleicht zwanzig Prozent verlieren. Meinst du diese Berechnungen haben die nicht gemacht?
Und wenn sie dir auf einmal irgendwie mit dieser, wenn sie dir dann da deine Netzneutralität beschneiden und dir irgendwelche Sachen wegnehmen, dich zum Zusatzpa,
verpflichten, damit wir irgendwie noch auf anderen Ports als achtzig und äh vier vier drei sprechen darfst oder so. Äh meinst du, da haben die nicht im Auge,
wie viele Jahre du da noch an die gebunden bist? Und das nämlich genau dann,
nach drei Jahren der Drops eben gelutscht ist. Das ist halt so, dass wir uns an den Mist gewöhnen, der uns zugemutet wird. Und wir können's halt nur am,
Schnell bekämpfen, ja? Wenn ich eine Drei-Jahres-Vertragsbindung habe und die mir nach einem halben Jahr irgendwie meine meine Netzneutralität vollständig zerschießen, dann habe ich mich zweieinhalb Jahre später haben wir uns leider alle da dran gewöhnt, dass wir diesen Kampf verloren haben.
So, deswegen müssen da äh, wenn man,
man diese Vertragsbindung kürzen. Und Oettinger will ja aber auch nicht bessere Sachen für die Kunden,
sondern er will ja einfach nur Planungssicherheit,
für die Investition für die Investoren. Ja, also mit anderen Worten, denen Gewinne sichern,
und das ist genau.
Finden wir nicht so geil jetzt. Um's mal ein bisschen zurückhalten.
Nein, es ist ganz besonders dumm und das ist auch wirklich mein ja.
Ähm gibt schon mal einen Einblick, was wir so in den nächsten Jahren, an weiteren, interessanten Vorschlägen.
Von ihm zu erwarten haben, ja.
So sieht's aus. Ja, ansonsten gibt's äh noch gute und äh schlechte Nachrichten,
aus dem Feld der Rechtsverfolgung im falschherringen Bereich.
Die einzige gute Nachricht in dem Zusammenhang ist, dass,
einer der Gründer auf jeden Fall das,
Gesicht der gesamten Gruppe. Ähm heute, heute.
Heute oder gestern, ja.
Aus dem Gefängnis entlassen wurde, wo er jetzt so einige Monate verbringen musste,
ähm das war sicherlich kein Spaß,
ähm fünfzehn Kilo hat er abgenommen, hieß es und ja, ich meine.
Und dann weiter für das gute kämpfen zum Beispiel,
äh bei mir auch zu verdanken haben,
Äh und bei diesem äh Krypto Messenger, den er da jetzt vor einiger Zeit schon angekündigt hatte.
Und ja, willkommen zurück und er war, glaube ich, jetzt fünf oder sechs Monate da drin.
Hat aber auch noch im Prinzip äh,
größere Menge an Geldes zurückzuzahl
immer noch ausreichend beklagenswert
Aber immerhin ist er nicht im Knast. Im Knast dafür ist sein Kollege.
Ne.
Genau. Das ist der Dritte im Bunde, nach dem Jahr, wie wir schon berichteten, der
Gottfried, der zweite jetzt auch gerade in Dänemark nochmal verurteilt wurde und noch so die ein oder andere Strafmaßnahme,
vor Augen hat, jetzt Friedrich Nee, der hat sich in.
Der hatte sich in Laus niedergelassen äh nach der,
Verurteilung und hat gesagt, das äh ist kein Problem
er kann sich jetzt gerne für die nächsten fünf Jahre in Laos einen runterholen bis die Strafe verjährt ist oder was und äh das war so seine,
Seine Vision und das hat er dann wohl auch gemacht zusammen mit seiner Familie,
ähm ist in den letzten Jahren,
insgesamt äh siebenundzwanzig Mal nach Thailand eingereist
sein Visum erneuert hat denn er hat ja jetzt kein aotische Staatsbürgerschaft
Ähm das heißt, da musste mal, muss man, wenn man sich dann da länger auffällt, immer mal wieder kurz raus, ein neues Visum beantragen, wieder rein oder so, ne, damit man die
Und sowas hat er dann halt wohl sehr regelmäßig gemacht und ähm,
Plötzlich wurde er jetzt äh von der,
Thai boarder Polizei. Ähm.
Gefangen genommen, denn es gab ja einen Interpol ähm,
wie übersetzt man sowas? Ein Interpol-Haft-Befehl gegen ihn und äh sie haben ihn dann ähm.
Noch direkt irgendwie im Fernsehen präsentiert und haben gesagt, ha super, äh den bringen wir jetzt äh nach Schweden,
wo er dann seine Haftstrafe antreten kann.
Ja, da hat dann sicherlich äh Thailand in,
irgendeiner internationalen, diplomatischen Ebene irgendwo eins Highscore erzielt.
Das ist schon so stolz äh darauf sind ihn gefunden zu haben et cetera. Macht das schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als hätte es schon häufiger mal jemand nachgefragt.
Ja
Und dann geht der geht die Offensive,
ja, falschherring, keine Ahnung. Ähm Urheberrechtsverletzende Angebote, die im deutschen,
Sprachrohr beliebt sind weiter. Wir hatten ja schon über Kino X Punkt T O gesprochen. Ähm nun äh wurde das Portal Börse BZ,
Hops genommen,
da gab es einhunderteinundzwanzig Wohnungsdurchsuchungen in vierzehn Bundes äh Bundesländern,
und,
da will man jetzt also den Uploadern, also Börse BZ war so eine Art Forum,
musste man sich irgendwie auch registrieren mit einer E-Mail-Adresse, sehr elegante Lösung. Ähm,
und in diesen Foren konnte man dann da, glaube ich, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, so seine Rappecher-Links äh.
Posten und dann da irgendwie zur Verbreitung äh beitragen, ne. Also ähm,
Gegensatz zu Kino, T O, offenbar weniger moderiert,
ähm man konnte halt weiter so ein Forum, ne. Ich habe das irgendwann auch mal genutzt, sagen wir mal,
Jetzt haben sie die also auch Hops genommen, die GVU äh freut sich und ähm jetzt ist natürlich interessant, die Leute waren also mit E-Mail-Adressen, haben sich dort mit E-Mail-Adressen äh registriert und,
haben die Ermittler jetzt eine äh ganz interessante äh Methode genutzt. Und zwar haben sie.
Denjenigen diejenigen Accounts, die dort signifikant Links,
Jetzt muss man sich vorstellen, okay, du hast jetzt diese, du hast dieses Börse BZing irgendwie in der Hand, du hast die Kiste geordnet,
oder übernommen, ne? Mach sie auf ähm und dann ähm,
siehst du halt, dass da dieses Forum und hast quasi dann die Nutzer,
die dann sich mit ihren E-Mail-Adressen registriert haben und dann siehst du halt, was sie, was sie in diesen Link, in diesen Foren
gepostet haben. Und jetzt hast du natürlich das Problem, dass wenn Börse BZ irgendwie halbwegs sinnvoll,
wurde das Ding keine IP-Adressen gespeichert hat.
Und selbst wenn, kannst du ja nur irgendwie je nach Provider, sieben bis vierzehn Tage ungefähr,
noch eine Halterfeststellung zu einer IP-Adresse machen. Also, was haben sie gemacht? Sie haben sich die,
Auf die E-Mail-Adressen konzentriert und haben bei denen äh Nutzern, die bei deutschen E-Mail-Anbietern waren.
Bei dem E-Mail-Anbieter gesagt, sag uns mal, mit welcher IP-Adresse sich dieser Nutzer das nächste Mal bei dir einloggt.
Oder das letzte Mal bei dir eingeloggt hat. Und dann konnten sie natürlich wieder die Feststellung machen und dann konnten sie den Leuten irgendwie ähm ans Leder,
ja und äh da gibt's halt jetzt irgendwie einen, der berichtet, also die Kanzlei mit dem,
Ähm vertritt da eben äh offensichtlich einige dieser Nutzer und berichtet über diese ähm,
Art der Feststellung, mit dem man da den Leuten,
Entgegengekommen ist, was auch wieder nur heißt, ne, für so einmal
Anmeldungen in in nutzt man natürlich dann zum Beispiel so was wie die,
Anonbox des CCC und nicht irgendwie sein,
nachname, Vorname, Nachname, HSI sechsundneunzig at Web DE oder was, ne? Weil das äh eben.
Auch langfristig dann noch zu Problemen führen kann. Ja, ärgerlich. Börse BZ. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe das,
Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Also es, aber es ist erstaunlich, ne? Also, dass diese Urheberrechtssache nochmal, ich,
für mich war's ja so, so netzpolitisch irgendwie auch so ein Thema, was irgendwie jetzt natürlich,
nicht mehr so groß,
Aber ähm ach so, die wichtige die wichtige Info, die,
sicherlich die Hörerin noch umtreibt. Wer sich da nur als Downloader betätigt hat und nicht selber gepostet hat, ist ja nach deutschem Urheberrecht, das war ja in der letzten Sendung auch schon entsprechend äh angesprochen nicht,
äh Ziel bösartiger Strafverfolgung jetzt, ne, aber.
Die.
Das Gesetz ist eben auch so, ne? Die die zur Verfügungsteller sind diejenigen, die große Strafen bekommen.
So, dann ähm aber das heißt, das heißt, dass ja.
Aber das heißt, das heißt, dass jetzt einfach mal kurz äh innerhalb von zwei Wochen die zwei großen,
beliebten faltherigen Anlaufpunkte in Deutschland platt gemacht wurden.
Gibt's sonst keine weiteren?
Weiß ich nicht, aber Kino, diese Kino, TO Kino XTO-Sache, war auf jeden Fall was, was man viel gehört hat so im,
was was Nutzer genutzt haben und Börse BZ äh eben auch, ne. Ich meine, wenn die mit hundert, wenn die hundertvierzig Wohnungen für den Mist durchsuchen, das machen sie nicht, weil das Ding irgendwie ein Nischenphänomen ist, ne.
Na ja, na gut, aber das steht da in der Regel wahrscheinlich auch wieder das nächste System gleich bereit.
Ja, aber vielleicht dieses Mal irgendwie äh als Hin-Service. Zwei,
äh wurde äh ein ein Silk Road wurde auch wieder aufgemacht. Äh diesmal äh,
auch auf wieder sehr ungünstige Art und Weise, da äh es wird, die machen.
Eng. Die machen's eng. Es wird eng. Tja, Tim hat schon den Finger an seinem.
Ich weiß gar nicht, äh wie diesmal die Leute, die nicht auch wieder irgendeinen dummen Fehler.
Auf eine auf seine eigene E-Mail-Adresse registriert war.
Hm
Also kleine Parallele hier zum Börse BZ-Fall,
Aber wie sie jetzt genau an den den hidden Service angegriffen haben, habe ich mich gar nicht mit auseinandergesetzt.
Ich auch nicht, wegen diese Information, ihr könnt das auch alles nachlesen, denn wir haben ja immer ganz tolle Links und Notes, die ihr sicherlich nach jeder Sendung nochmal ausführlich würdigt und,
Gutachtet. Anklickt und die Ergebnisse, die daraus rauskommen, auch intensiv studiert
denn ihr seid ja die besten Hörer, die man sich vorstellen kann und dementsprechend erwarten wir ein solches Verhalten. Stimmt's?
Tim, das klang jetzt nicht besonders ihr seid ja die besten Hörer, die wir erwarten, dass uns ein bisschen.
Gesagt, dass wir tolle Links haben, die gehören auch angeklickt.
Ich weiß nicht, die gehen alle nur zu Spiegel.
Nicht alle.
Nicht alle. Haben wir auch dabei.
Bleibt äh eigentlich nur noch ähm.
Die tollsten, aber tollsten, Moment, aber tollsten Termine hinzuweisen,
wieder was Schönes in Berlin und wir haben was schönes in Berlin,
und in Berlin haben wir am siebzehnten November zwanzig vierzehn im Angebot,
Berliner Kongresscenter, das dann ausnahmsweise mal wieder von CCC-Anhängern bevölkert werden wird,
um einen weiteren Jahrestag. Daran ist ja der Club auch nicht so richtig äh arm äh zu feiern und sind wieder mal dreißig Jahre nachdem letztes Jahr schon dreißig Jahre,
Kongress entstanden,
jetzt eben auch nochmal dreißig Jahre äh BTX Hack, also es war nicht Entschuldigung, sondern,
Kongresse ist der dreißigste Kongress, dreißig Jahre Kongress haben wir ja im Prinzip erst dieses Jahr,
was wir die Gehalt wissen. Vorher gab's ja dann auch noch diesen gloriosen BTX Hack,
der damals den CCC überhaupt in die Öffentlichkeit gebracht hat und um all das nochmal zusammenzufassen, zu beschreiben und so weiter,
äh die war Holland Stiftung eingeladen und auch auf ihrer Webseite schon seit längerem einen Countdown geliefert und ihr könnt da am siebzehnten November hingehen.
Darf ich, darf ich auch noch mal?
Nee, eigentlich nicht, aber ich mache jetzt mal eine Ausnahme.
In Berlin,
gibt's nächstes Jahr eine Veranstaltung, die natürlich jetzt so ungefähr die,
gekündigte Veranstaltung jemals in unserer Beliebtenreihe der Terminvorstände Vorschläge ist,
nämlich die Republika vom fünften bis siebten Mai zweitausendfünfzehn in der Station,
die heute der Vorverkauf angefangen hat, weshalb wir sie hier an dieser Stelle überhaupt erwähnen.
Genau, denn nur der frühe Vogel äh kriegt äh das billige Ticket.
Billig ist das nun wirklich.
Naja, das billigere Ticket. Das günstigere Ticket. Das Ticket, was weniger kostet.
Dass das nicht ganz so frech teure Ticket.
Genau das. Das wollt ihr haben.
Und ansonsten haben wir jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr viel zu sagen, beziehungsweise sollten wir jetzt definitiv mal die Klappe halten, damit ihr euch mal wieder anderen Dingen zuwenden könnt und die ganzen anderen interessanten Podcasts durchhören könnt, die sonst noch auf eurem Gerät lauern, oder?
Jetzt auch mal was anderes machen. Also bis bald, tschüss. Tschau, tschau.
Tschau, tschau.